ha ha ha go get away get away get away
all right that's a good start
ok yeah I'm great so great ah go away
boy candy I throw a barrel TT yeah I've
got here oh yeah you don't wanna do dis
oh this is gonna be a problem for you go
go go ha ha ha ha ha ha let you find my
barrel barrel come on Oh what the [ __ ]
Oh Oh all right moving on
come on come on come on ha ha I know
that sound
hey you can't fool me ha ha what what is
that oh whoa where'd it go where'd he go
oh yeah there you go
where'd it go what no it's nothing
that's nothing
hi who are you oh the hell are you Oh
bring it on Oh bring it bring it
I'm gonna get you I'm gonna get you ahh
ahh yeah yeah
you wonder this oh yeah so great
ah oh no no boys you see the top of a
1000 foot uh when the chair oh okay
all right you got my chair oh good egg
meet you Oh believe me opening open I
waited to have a flashlight oh god oh
god oh god do it good oh yeah take that
oh oh so badass Oh what uh Wow Wow Oh
this all is wrong why the hell did you
even need the saw give me the saw oh man
I'll turn them off I'm so brave
oh look at me oh oh no no no no no yeah
yeah oh [ __ ] huh what what the [ __ ] Oh
No Oh what is that what is that oh I
don't like this oh but I'm brave oh [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you game oh [ __ ] you
next night yeah oh you big pervert I was
just gonna you know totally rescue her
for not ah I did good good get away
Oh fu man I'm tired I'm sick and tired
go away yeah f o fo was it aa dead end
Oh get away get away get away
hi what do you think you're doing Oh
what up Pro Dodge oh nothing nothing can
withstand the chair
yea-ah oh it's it's alive oh [ __ ] you
I'll get ready for a chair oh you are so
getting the chair Oh get oh I'll get
here
Oh fu man Oh Oh get away I'm trip got
[ __ ] in it get away
oh hey you Oh get away get away get away
get away
Oh F Oh F of Oh get away oh no oh no oh
no oh no oh no no okay
alright I got this I got this I got this
I got this I got it oh oh yeah I got it
I got it I got it oh oh come it yeah
alright yeah yeah oh yeah oh so great oh
I'm the best I'm the best oh look at me
up not up big brain muscles a braveness
juice everywhere oh yeah oh yeah oh oh
yeah